and minimalists
it's time it is time time for us to
start let's do it according to the
script you go first
all right all right go for it ready one
two three go
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast we discuss what it
means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua fields Millburn
and I am Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalist welcome episode 140
140 years we've been doing this Ryan man
times flown by today we're gonna eat
really well man thank you thank you very
much well today we're gonna talk about
buying things with with intentionality
right because it's minimalist it's not
like we don't buy anything we got a way
I gotta buy some stuff and we haven't
bought anything for a decade we're gonna
talk about buying things I got a little
bit of follow up before we happen to
these voicemail questions so last week
on the access episode Ryan we talked
with Ryan Delk from Omni and one of the
things we talked about were those birds
scooters oh dude did you try it yeah I
finally tried them this this weekend did
you fall no I didn't fall at all even
come close which I I was disappointed I
didn't fall cuz I'm usually so unstable
I think it's just I think it's a
confidence issue man like you tell
yourself you're unstable something as
soon as you get on something like you
project that I'm just really glad you
didn't hurt yourself man no I just I
think I've birdlegs so the next to it
yeah yeah we were riding him around West
Hollywood together and we and all over
the place we're doing dodgeball tonight
I might ride one down for our dodgeball
game this is three blocks for me
walking's for plebs these days no they
are a lot of fun dude yeah there's so
much more you enjoying dodgeball oh yeah
dude it's much worse than I thought
yeah it's uh god it's a lot of fun I
have a lot of fun and that's that's what
it's about it's about you know me going
having fun hanging out with some friends
it's not about winning or losing because
if I didn't make it about winning or
losing then I'd be really miserable yeah
it was disappointing like dude we did
alright it was four we were we were
three and four right that's not alright
Nicodemus I mean it's better than the
first week we were six and one yeah and
someone else wasn't there hey Becks yeah
you're listening to those backs no we
just started we just played a better
team this week and but yeah I really
enjoyed that one other bit of follow up
we we talked about you know we were
going on next week we're going on the
simply southern tour mm-hmm and a
hundred percent of the profits are going
to the gym city Marcus we're trying to
help build this nonprofit grocery store
in our hometown Dayton Ohio which is one
of the largest food deserts in the
country has one of largest food deserts
in the country and so if you want to
contribute to that you can do so at the
minimalists comm slash dayton we talked
about that for my birthday we're asking
folks to donate we're already a third of
the way there to the hundred thousand
dollars ryan so that's really good
credit woman we're a third of the way
there thank you to everyone so far who
has donated that is that's that's
incredible man that one third of the way
there now I've heard from some people
say I can't afford $37 that's okay
donate five bucks if you can't donate a
dollar if you can't every little bit is
going to help and if you can afford more
great $90 we'll provide a family with a
lifetime membership which which helps us
build this grocery store where there are
no grocery stores right now so if you
want to hear more about that we'll put a
link to it in the show notes if you want
to read more about it it's just the
minimalists comm slash dayton or you can
join us for the simply southern tour
next week we're going out with the folks
from Ramsey solutions we'll be out there
with Rachael Cruz and Chris Hogan and
Anthony O'Neill and Alabama and Kentucky
and Tennessee we're doing three tourist
offs we're gonna talk about money and
minimalism all the details over at our
website the minimalists com a slash tour
Ryan what have you let go of recently
God the reason I asked I did a video
about this yeah I can't think of
anything of I mean just probably
something but I are you clinging to
everything being put on the spot to give
it anything that's why I was why that's
why I asked because some t-shirts like I
donated cuz I got some new t-shirts so I
donated some old t-shirts yeah exactly I
did the same thing so I do that I had
cardigan that I hadn't worn with the
9090 rule I hadn't used in the last 90
days I'm like okay be honest with
yourself Josh are you going to actually
use this cardigan in the next nine days
I suppose I could have like had to force
myself to wear it but I was like do I
want to wear this in the next 90 days
there was a pair of pants I got rid of
as well that I hadn't worn in the last
90 days wasn't gonna wear in the next 90
days and I'm back to one and a half
pairs of pants I say one and a half
because you've a pair of shorts no I
have a couple of pairs I've at least
three pairs of shorts because I go to
the sauna regularly so I need more than
one pair I don't wear my pants into the
sauna though but I just replaced these
pants because there's several holes in
them at this point and I've had them
sewn and resewn anyway so I just got
another pair of pair so these are about
to get donated dude I just got um so the
I have these uh these like athletic
sweats on right they're like the most
comfortable pants I've ever had in my
life oh maybe I'll say that for the
recommendation the added value but
regardless yeah yeah for the added value
portion of the show but I bought a
second pair of them because they
discontinued this pair okay
and somehow like the drawstrings got
caught up in the they're just all like
chewed up and messed up uh-huh um and
these get dirtier like I have to wash
these yeah compared to like the jeans
that I have sure so I was like man hey
think about get a second part I went to
the store to get they're like oh we
discontinued this so I got a used pair
off eBay uh-huh which cost me like half
as much right but um but yeah dude like
I've it's I bought something I let
something go and I bought something yeah
yeah so that's sort of the it you
accidentally stumbled into the one in
one out rule right right it was like
three t-shirts out one pair of pants in
but yeah well I like that I I like
setting up these arbitrary rules
especially when we're trying to let go
of stuff at first like having if you
want to bring one thing in letting go of
ten things at once you know the the one
in and out rule it's a good one forces
you to like all of a sudden think about
dude how much is this really gonna add
value because I have to get rid of ten
other things and it helps you let go at
the same time so the reason I asked this
question it was I did at one of those
living room conversations over on our
YouTube channel
everyone who's watching this podcast on
YouTube right now we're we're doing the
the video version and next week I'm
super excited because Matt's gonna be in
here to film a three camera version oh
my god so we can we can have different
angles yeah we're gonna have different
angles Ryan oh my god I'm gonna look
three times as handsome but anyway I
don't eat these living room
conversations because I posted this this
question on out on the minimalists
Twitter feed what's one thing you like
you've let go recently and we just got
hundreds of responses 187 responses what
how exact and so I just printed out a
few of these to take a look because
often we think about things that we let
go of like I like my cardigan or your
shirt or this extra pair of pants or
whatever you know some of these other
responses were encouraging I like Oliver
said I let go of the idea that
everything needs to be perfect before
taking any action Bravo Oliver I've says
I let go of having my smartphone as an
apparent organ extension of my hands I
forget who it was who called the
smartphone the 79th organ but it feels
that way some yes I panic when I like oh
my god I forgot my phone I'm in line
somewhere what am I gonna do without my
phone right and in in a way like we're
much more aware of this organ than we
are of the other organs like if you
didn't tell me I had kidneys I wouldn't
know I've never actually seen my kidneys
Thank You Lee yeah it's funny for me
when I forget my phone I used to panic
but now I'm like oh sweet now I have an
excuse as to why I didn't get back to
someone yeah and this is a legit excuse
I didn't have my phone with sorry did I
my phone with me yeah and and it's it's
truthful it's not like well I'm just
gonna respond to someone with that it's
like I legitimately didn't have my phone
with me or it was turned off or whatever
Jerry said I let go seven suits 15
shirts for athletic warm-up suits and 15
pairs of pants who's that 2008 Josh
Milburn yeah seriously it's like that's
light work for my 2008 so who else what
else
peppermint Belle said I
I go of other people's expectations I
realize I'm not happy trying to be the
person other people think I should be a
man dude yes living up to other people's
expectations that is that is one of the
most detrimental things we can do man
recipe for discontent right really is
yeah unbelievable
Melanie said I let go of 3/4 of my
closet my guess is she enjoys that other
1/4 a whole lot more mm-hmm
who else Elise said I let go of my
snooze button it's a struggle but I'm
getting more done in the morning now
than ever you know what I realized it I
don't even send an alarm anymore
yeah if I go to bed early I wake up
early yes it's like it's just how my
body is programmed I was talking to when
I did the health problems podcast I was
talking to dr. Tommy wood and
Christopher Kelly about this and and ice
actually sleep more now than I did well
certainly more than I did invite my 20s
because I I wore it as a badge of honor
I slept for hours last night what are
you lazy people do what I can do on four
hours of sleep yeah I can look how
healthy I am look what I can do in this
unhealthy state Bex and I were talking
about this yesterday I think the the the
second biggest contributing factor to me
improving my health and you can go back
and listen to that episode was episode
138 but it was the longest podcast that
we've ever done but it's because we had
all these little different segments
about sleep and exercise and and
chemical sensitivities and libido and
erectile dysfunction and like all of
these different discussions we had
little five-minute discussions on so it
was almost like having 15 miniature
podcasts all sort of sandwiched together
I have with with both of them but what I
was talking to Beck's about yesterday is
I think sleep is the second largest
contributing factor to my improving my
health and making sure I'm getting seven
to ten hours of sleep a night yeah now
now I say seven to ten because two
nights ago I got I got 10 hours of sleep
my body needed it and I mean ER I woke
up before and I'm like okay I'm ready to
get up and start writing and I'm like am
I really and I said okay I'm gonna give
myself permission to get back
better for a half an hour and just sleep
and see if if this is why Barney's and I
did that again today
I got up around 4:45 and am i okay I'll
give myself until about 5:30 and at 5:30
if I'm still awake then I'll get out of
pet and I'd that's what I did and I
wrote for an hour I did some exercising
and so it's like it's letting your body
be the alarm clock is sort of what you
were talking about yeah and letting your
body determine okay last night I only
needed seven hours but maybe tonight I
need more because it was a strenuous day
or whatever yeah I notice Baxter's
really working hard now on her she's
like training again so like she is like
crazy crazy fit right now just doing a
lot of endurance and like CrossFit style
sort of workouts and so she and a cardio
on top of it
but as a result she requires more sleep
and you know Ella she's a tornado every
night though she sleeps for 11 hours
sometimes 12 hours a night so jealous I
wish I could sleep that many hours but
here's the thing
also maybe if I was a tornado for 12
hours a day then I would need that that
kind of thing I remember I think it was
Roger Federer it was definitely tennis
player but I think was Federer who said
if I don't get at least 11 hours more
likely 12 hours then there's a problem
and so what he's saying is I have to
sleep half the time because of the
energy I expend and so yeah letting go
of the snooze button is one way to do
them they ex said I let go of my job I
retired at age 54 last Friday's Congrats
congratulations awesome that's funny I'm
reading this book which again is gonna
be part of the added value portion so I
won't say the name of the book but it's
talking about retirement uh-huh and how
the age sixty five and a half to retire
mm-hmm that was that's based off of the
government figuring out when you're
gonna die actuary terrace hey you know
what at 65 and a half you got about
three years of life left on average
mm-hmm we won't we will have to pay
Social Security for only two and a half
years because when you turn 68 you're
probably gonna die so yeah 65 and a half
is the retirement age yeah and the fact
that we have allowed ourselves to accept
an age as a retirement age it's actually
it hurts
with retirement I was talking to you and
Mariah and Beck's about this book I just
ordered it they didn't have it at the
local bookshop [ __ ] jobs oh yeah
yeah yeah I'm looking forward to
thinking of that and if it's any good
maybe we can ask the author to come on
but he he's in LA I don't know where he
is but I know he's he's done a few
interviews and a couple of them were in
LA but anyway he basically talks about
how we've invented these sort of wrote
jobs that require you know an hour two
hours of work a day or a week sometimes
or some jobs that require no work at all
and then we have to justify that job to
our boss repeatedly so we're often
living these lives that aren't
meaningful doing work that doesn't feel
meaningful to us but we have to pretend
it's meaningful to the people around
them back to what have you let go of
recently geek ster said I let go of a
couple of toxic people yeah man yeah
that's this is the hardest thing to let
go of yes indeed and and often some of
the most important because here's the
thing we often think like I let go of
this relationship what am I going to
fill that space with that time with
there are seven billion people in this
earth and even if you live in a small
town with 20,000 people there are 20,000
other people you can find people who
aren't toxic who are gonna bring you
down who are in fact gonna lift you up
and support you unless you're making bad
decisions yourself unless you're the top
being the toxic person which I know you
and I have talked about in our past
quite often we've been the toxic one in
the relation solutely and so often it
starts with fixing ourselves but then
once we fix ourselves letting go of the
toxic relationship sometimes the best
way to love someone is from a distance
Robin I like this one Robin said there's
a small black stone I've been carrying
around with me all the time I put it on
the wall yesterday when I was walking
into college so that someone else could
have it so maybe that's a stone that the
users sort of to remind yourself of an
experience or something sentimental
Reese tone have you ever seen those with
the little dimples in the middle of them
yeah they're only rub it with your thumb
when you're worried yeah it's like
one of the second was the first fidgets
Penner yeah exactly the worst was the
first pigeon spinner yes that there's
the minimal max the first minimal maxim
Shawn vodka Shawn's riding down the
worry stones and fidgets spinners but
the the to me it's a metaphor because
sometimes we carry around these things
worry stone it's like think about the
name there the connotation that has I'm
gonna carry this thing around that helps
me worry yeah or I'm gonna carry around
this extra weight that literally does
nothing what a perfect metaphor for
consumerism or holding on to baggage or
holding on to toxic toxic relationships
but here's the thing sometimes the
things we bring in are beautiful but
they serve no purpose maybe it did bring
you joy and so here's a different
metaphor even those things that once
brought you joy can eventually just get
in the way and it's time to let go maybe
someone else can get joy from it yeah I
think Robin Robin experienced that what
else do we have who else let go of
something here let's do one or two more
and then we'll put a link to this
Twitter thread in the show notes over at
the minimalists comm slash podcast let's
see here that's a repeat of the previous
page well I guess that's it Ryan
but it's interesting thinking about what
what things we let go of often aren't
things aren't material things aren't
possessions for me minimalism was like
the the the initial thing was the things
but then it was getting past the things
and letting go of that habits letting go
of that relationships letting go of
distractions I know a few people and
this thread talked about some of the
distractions they were letting go of you
know the Facebook account that they were
just incessantly checking or a second
email account Hey yeah so like there are
these different things that we like we
use to distract ourselves these
different habits that that we've formed
over time and letting go of the
distractions is something that
that I think resonates with a lot of
people and sometimes we're just
distracted by the things in our life
which is a perfect segue to this New
Yorker cartoon maybe you can see this if
you're on YouTube I'm not sure I'll hold
it up here for the camera thought the
zoom in full screen and zoom in yes this
is New Yorker cartoon and it has so if
you think about hunter who has like the
trophy heads on their wall I was like a
deer and I don't know what do people
hunt giraffe oh no dude sure head on
your wall really high ceilings
yeah rhinoceros head deer heads moose
heads whatever they might be
this one the caption says I'm a bargain
hunter and then there's like like a case
of seltzer water on the wall yeah 12
pack of soft toilet paper it's great
jeez it's it's yes it's so easy to get
caught in that it's like the group
hunting or not group hunting but the um
what do they call them in like the
extreme couponers yeah yeah just
couponing I mean there are people who
who turned that into a hobby and I go
out of my way to avoid the sort of
coupon discount thing if it's there and
it's available I will certainly use it
I'm not gonna turn away free money but
I'm not gonna buy something because it's
a bargain just because I have a coupon
that shouldn't be the thing that tips
the scale toward buying the thing hmm
what should tip the scale is it does
this add value is it gonna serve a
purpose is the best use of my money no
not uh oh it's 15% off I'd be dumb not
to buy it right because of course it's a
100 percent off if you if you don't buy
it anyway we should probably dive into
these voicemails what do you think Ryan
let's do it our first question today is
from Jacqueline in Detroit struggling
with my minimalist journey I started out
and when I found you guys it was like a
breath of fresh air and now I seem to be
really struggling with putting this into
use 100% of the time most of this lens
to consumerism so I believe that I am
shopping compulsively and I don't know
how to stop necessarily you know the
IKEA mano
from Fight Club when they talk about
this couch like once I get this couch
I'll be fine or what lamp defines me
that's totally me and I don't know how
to stop it because reading about it or
listening to you guys I'm totally on
board philosophically but then when it
comes to putting it into practice I have
these moments of weakness where I just
revert back and I do not know what to do
so Ryan tell me what you think about
this analogy I was thinking about this
so so Jacqueline's saying you know she's
talking about shopping compulsively she
can't apply apply minimalism 100% and
and she's struggling to like sort of
feel complete as if the next purchase is
going to make us feel complete and in
the the analogy or maybe metaphor here
of dieting I often think about there
isn't there probably is not a perfect
diet for anyone although it's highly
individual right but minimalism isn't
sort of the anorexic equivalent of
dieting right my partner Rebecca she
she's a dietitian and a nutritionist and
so she has clients and she works within
several of whom struggle with anorexia
or bulimia and she's worked with a lot
of college students back when she was at
the University for a decade who
struggled with those and that's not a
that's not a diet that is a disorder the
same way that hoarding or OCD can be a
disorder I have OCD and and minimalism
has helped me sort of keep that under
control in a way because it's it's been
easier not to - that there are two sides
of the sort of OCD spectrum I finished
watching that show that you recommended
there in the added value evil genius oh
yeah and there are several hoarders in
there and and that's just that that's a
type of OCD in a way where it's like
compulsively holding on to things right
and and I think about OCD or minimalism
that is not they're not the same thing
people often mistake minimalism - for
with having
nothing living as a ascetic and III
don't want Jacqueline to think that like
well I I can't apply minimalism 100% of
the time so I can't apply minimalism at
all I don't think it's about I don't
think it's about stopping shopping
because she said how do I stop it's
about figuring out what things are
appropriate to buy yeah it's not right
there yeah I see what you're saying to
me it sounds like she is using shopping
as a pacifier and I think the way I
interpreted the question was is how do I
stop using shopping as a pacifier to
stop those impulses so yeah I agree with
you 100% we do not have to stop shopping
it's not about you know becoming a
minimalist and never buying anything
again or becoming a minimalist and
buying only used items or like you said
there isn't this this there is not this
totalitarian set of rules that each
minimalist has to abide by just like
diet right the writer is not well here's
the diet you must follow their rhythm
that will work better for others that
for certain people than other people
right and especially like say
Jacqueline's got you know a husband and
six kids like what they buy as a family
is gonna be much different than what
Mariah and I buy as a family sure so
yeah just blanketing any type of rules
um I don't think it's going to really I
don't think it's gonna help Jacqueline
here I think I think what's gonna help
Jacqueline is is her finding better
habits to replace shopping with yes so
shopping as a dude it's tempting for me
as one of the minimalists living in Los
Angeles it's like when I'm bored I have
totally had I'm gonna go to the Apple
store because now it's three blocks from
my place right it's not you know used to
be three hours drive through two states
to get there how do I get this bow
cannon at least three blocks from my my
place and everything you know it I think
the last I um I lost I lost I lost my
air pods so I want to replace them I
almost lost mine twice and
last two weeks do I found them both time
I really hope that someone just like
picked them up and they're using them
but like my fears that they fell out out
and like now they're in the the cushion
of this like it buried in this couch in
this Airbnb I was staying at anyway I
went to the Apple store this was a
couple months ago and went in there to
buy the air pods and dude like it was so
hard for me to like walk out with just
the air pods but but my kind of going
down to rabisu no that's good so what
what did you see there that your it was
like oh dude they had like they had
really good Bluetooth speakers they had
you know the iPhone acts they had or the
iPhone 10 they had cases and protectors
and bluetooth gadgets that will hook to
your phone and computer and I mean it's
just like this this world of convenience
new computer that they yeah that they
offer you at at the at the Apple Store
yeah it's funny I I was listening to
someone recently they were talking about
how they went into the Apple store and
they actually they were shocked because
the the pros Duncan Trussell he said
that he went in there I like to replace
his computer and the the person Apple
was like what are you using it for and
he's like well I you know I write on it
and I added a little bit of audio and
they're like well this the computer you
have only four years old it's fine for
what you're doing right now is there a
reason you want to upgrade you know I
was like my mind was blown that this
company who sells more products than any
other company on the face of the earth
can say hey maybe you don't need the new
product right now and that that's a good
thing it was just it's not the company
said that was one individual who said
that I don't know if that's their
corporate ethos or something right but
it made me realize like I anytime I go
to Apple store like I had a Apple Care
issue a few months ago and I had to
bring something in there and I
immediately looked at like oh look at
the shiny new MacBook I mean I've got my
my MacBook Pro or whatever the hell it
is that my laptop's I've had you know we
bought them the same time 2014 maybe I
don't
yeah it was yeah it was was when we took
Shawn on yeah so twenty thirteen or
fourteen whatever I was
and we all have the same computer
basically and I bet I go in there and
I'm like oh that one is shinier than
mine and look at the the keys on it are
slightly different it's more aerodynamic
aerodynamic am I gonna throw this thing
so so for me man like the way the way
that I avoid like I guess acting on that
impulse to go shop or to go even a
window shop man like that's tempting
dude I mean there are there's a plethora
of places to shop here in Los Angeles
and window shopping even that that's
just gonna that's going to develop the
desire even more it adds more temptation
right exactly
so for me like I I try to stay as active
as possible whether it's working out
whether it's going on walks
whether it's mountain biking whether
it's surfing whether it's going to your
house to watch a movie yeah I try to
fill my time with as many get that extra
time I should say I try to fill my extra
time up with as many either active
things or the communal things where I'm
experiencing something with with a
friend or with the community but but yes
sitting around and in doing nothing of
being bored watch especially watching TV
like that is that right there is going
to make you want to shop more yeah so
here's a here's what I would recommend
for Jacqueline is if she wants to curb
this desire first and foremost
Jacqueline get as many advertisements
out of your life as possible so how does
Jacqueline do that get rid of cable get
rid of it or watch only the stuff you
record and fast fast-forward through the
commercials yeah uh pay the extra three
four five however many dollars it costs
to get the ad-free version of whatever
it is that you're using to entertain
yourself pay that extra little bit with
YouTube I find that your premium and
it's like twelve bucks a month and it's
the best twelve dollars I spend every
month absolutely because I there is
a single ad ever unless someone tries
now people are doing the sponsored
things inside like if we were doing ads
on this podcast all of a sudden you like
our YouTube channel we could be making
lots of money if we had ads turn on our
YouTube you know but it doesn't align
with our ethos so we have those turned
off so even if you watch our videos on
the free version you don't get served up
ads right unless YouTube does something
without our permission so right alright
but but but Jacqueline think about all
the ways that you take in advertisements
using at if you're not using an ad
blocker for anyone out there if you're
not using an ad blocker it's free yeah
just Google free ad blocker and pick the
first one that comes up that's what I
did in fact Shawn in the show I don't
know what the name of my ad blocker is
but I'll figure it out before the end of
the show and Shawn if you could put that
into the show notes put an ad blocker
under your computer but Jacqueline all
the advertisements that you see they are
affecting you
they are seating in your conscience they
are making you want to buy things they
are giving you they're adding to this
impulse that you already have they're
playing to that impulse so so the first
step is get rid of as many
advertisements as possible yeah and the
thing you talked about with replacing I
really like that right so so it's not
about stopping just stopping because
then it's gonna be hard it's like you
just stopped shopping and they not I'll
stand here stoic Lee and do nothing
well that that that's not reasonable
because you're good now you're just
gonna ruminate about the things you're
not purchasing so I think it's about
replacing and so some questions ask
there's what can I replace this with
right because shopping is an activity so
what are the activities it might be
dodgeball it might be hiking it might be
you're going to the aquarium with your
kids III don't know what your life looks
like but what do you want it to look
like and then absolutely maybe it's
meditating exactly so you know that
meditation alone will help with those
impulses yes
although meditating alone if you're just
doing that you'll probably ruminate and
at first and so I find activities that
help you stay focused and then peppering
in the meditation be sure will be really
helpful and then and so meditation is a
definitely more meaningful experience
than shopping we both agree with that
right yeah so maybe the question to ask
then if you're getting ready to go
shopping is what is a more meaningful
experience than
this and if you ask yourself that
question you're gonna that's a better
question you're gonna start getting
better answers yeah Shawn also please
put in the shownotes the links to the
meditations that we did for the 10%
happier app yeah I will the 10% half of
your app and then if you are a patreon
supporter we have a meditation on there
we have one meditation or on our patreon
page we'll probably do some more in the
future as well yeah they're just like
two three
what's a long as when we did five
minutes maybe yeah nine minutes or
something like that yeah that that is
just a meditation on not consuming
anti-consumerism meditation so okay so
that that's another thing Jacqueline can
do is find something to change your
state when you get that impulse so maybe
you want to go buy the latest greatest
stylish lamp and you get that impulse
stop yourself listen to a three-minute
meditation whether it's Josh and i's
meditation or someone else's it doesn't
matter change your state somehow stop
for three minutes to reconsider and if
you still feel and go buy the lamp
afterwards okay great change your
approach next time but you got to find
some way to to interrupt that impulse
that you get I like that podcast Sean if
we could get that other meditation we
recorded for then and put it on our
patreon feed that way we'll have two
meditations up there both meditations
that we did so you can find those on his
10% half of your app as well and then if
your patreon supporter you can find them
on our patreon page you just click on
there's different tags you just click
the meditation tag we'll put it on there
shortly after this episode goes up so
within a week of this episode going up
what we'll put the the other one the
other anti-consumerism meditation up
there for you and a couple other things
i recommend ryan here just recommend
thinking about really is that you'll
never be complete right that that couch
that you buy will not make you more
complete it will not make you a better
human being
ideally though for we buy the right
things for our life they will enhance
they'll amplify they'll augment our
experience of life sure you came over to
my house we had movie night this this
past weekend me you and backs and Mariah
and and we sat on a couch is we didn't
sit on just hardwood floors or or so
that that couch augmented our experience
for the evening we
drank water out of glasses instead of
putting our head under the faucet right
we maybe you guys did we hypocrite we
who we ate dinner off of plates yes
instead of just pouring the food onto
the table no of course of course we need
some stuff in and those things augmented
our experience however let's say I
bought more plates and I had seven sets
of plates at my house
that wouldn't have improved our evening
at all in fact it probably just got in
the way because also I'm thinking about
which plate should we use this this
evening should I break out the fine
china tonight I like this idea Rob and
Kristen Bell they they always use the
fine china they got some really nice
China for their wedding gift or some
anniversary thing or whatever so even
our regular just normal breath noise
they'll break out the really because
they like use the nice things as opposed
to just storing them long-term yeah use
the things that you have if you're using
them if they serve a purpose to bring
you joy then great also the author
Christina cook she talks about will put
a link to her website she also has a
book called the joy of missing out it's
sort of the the opposite of the fear of
missing out mmm it's the the joy Jomo
yeah yeah it's Jomo and if you can to
the FOMO that's that that's yeah instead
of phone was just so we all have the
fear of missing out because it's like
how can I be more complete if I just buy
the thing this thing this thing I'll be
more complete and if not I'm missing out
I didn't even check the tweet I need to
check this and it's the reason I don't
have social media on my phones because I
always feel like I'm going to check the
next thing what do people say to my
Instagram post and like I just get
caught up in the missing out and and so
maybe there's a joy of missing out that
Christina crook talks about but I think
there's a step in between what I would
call wome oh okay the welcoming of
missing outs and maybe you don't get the
joy yet but you just bask in the fact
that yes you pause and you let out the
breath huh I am this now I had missing
out it's alright yeah I'm gonna welcome
this it's okay yeah because no matter
what even if you get that couch you
get all the knick knacks is gonna make
your life perfect it's not gonna be
perfect no and you're still you're still
missing out on 99.999% of everything
else that's out there and letting go is
really hard right so we did we went
through the whole thing of what have you
let go of recently that's that's a hard
exercise and it gets easier the more you
let go but how about this not buying
something is your future self letting go
in advance
yeah or you're letting go of that
impulse yeah yeah you can tweet that
show and that's a minimal maximum for
you not buying something is your future
self letting go and in advance so it's
like saving money now so you don't have
interest compounds this is sort of like
reverse interest in a way you I have to
let go of the thing you don't buy yeah
and and so think about it that way is do
I really want to have to deal with this
later I want to deal with the packaging
and the charging of the thing and do I
want to have to deal with once this
thing is not serving its purpose or
maybe it's never actually gonna serve
its purpose I just got really excited it
was an aspirational purchase ya know
you're at the apple store and you're
like oh I bet I could use the Bluetooth
thing and the cable and maybe that case
will do this and then then you're like
but when I really think about it oh
that's what someone else would get from
it that's not might not be what I would
actually give ya from exactly another
thing that Jacqueline said that stands
out to me she said you know she's bought
in you know with the philosophy of
minimalism but having a hard time acting
on it you know I thought I started
thinking about like I used to be bought
into the idea of exercise mm-hmm I used
to be bought into the idea of healthy
eating and you can be bought into an
idea if you do not take action then it
is just an idea and I think Jacqueline
should look at this as diet or exercise
like what what can you do to start
taking massive action towards living a
more simple life and we're gonna talk
about hearing a little bit kind of some
stuff that we consider before we buy
before we buy things and Jacqueline you
can use you know that the things that we
consider or you can make up your own
structure but I know when it comes to
diet I have to have a structure to my
diet yeah
it's a very simple structure with
exercise I have to have structure with
that like Mariah
we get to the gym or we'd try to workout
not even try we do we work out at least
five days a week hands down at least for
45 minutes of five days a week this week
it'll be seven days this week yeah right
yeah it's awesome and like that
structure is what will help us to
continue to live a healthy lifestyle and
and continue to be in that exercise
routine and I'll tell you as soon as
like we go on tour dude I'm not gonna be
able to work out seven days a week and
when I come back and it's gonna be
harder for me to get back into that
structure I think you will be able to go
I think since you've set up this
structure and you feel really good about
it may not be the same workout right but
you can hit the elliptical for
forty-five minutes as soon as we get to
the Hampton Inn or wherever we're yeah
yeah I guess what I'm saying though is
that sometimes the structure will fall
apart a little bit yeah and Mariah and I
we have to really really rely on those
boundaries we set up for ourselves if we
don't then we will quickly just be on
the outside looking at the idea of
exercise instead of actually exercising
absolutely Jaclyn I love to send you a
copy of our book everything that remains
you mentioned the IKEA from Fight Club
there's an Ikea scene in everything that
remains as well so it's my marriage ins
my mother dies both in the same month
and of course in order to deal with in
order to cope while Rome is burning I am
shopping at IKEA and going through like
all the accouterments I'm buying for my
new apartment so I can make sure my life
is complete of course there are a bunch
of lessons I learned from that and that
scene I think will be really helpful for
you because it there were there were
certain epiphanies that I experienced in
that chapter and then the several
chapters thereafter so podcast Jean if
you could reach out to her and send her
an audio book version of everything that
remains it's my favorite thing that
we've ever created if you like our
podcast or like the audio book version
or if you want the eBook version or the
book book book book version then we'll
be happy to send that to you as well all
right our next question is from Leslie
in Denver two quick questions for you
guys
um one is that I was hoping you could
recommend some brands that you find
value in for when we actually do need to
buy something especially as we've gotten
rid of a lot of things that don't add
value so what are some valuable brands
that are maybe environment
friendly or religious quality that you
guys would recommend and to I'm
wondering if you could talk a little bit
about balancing your time to try to push
through a passion if you still are
working a nine-to-five finding a hard
time fitting in health and passion and
relationships and balancing it all right
Ryan brands that you trust is it coke or
is it Pepsi RC I I worked a dumb
question Josh next dumb question you're
such a hipster Sam's Cola you have a 14
ounce bottle of RC so I I worked at
americano in Middletown Ohio when I was
13
yeah it because you're allowed to work
at 13 back then apparently and there's
that summer I was turning 14 so it was
right before high school and we had like
the generic version of everything right
it was just like it was the generic
version of Six Flags or Kings I wonder
what yeah what Americana was the place
looks like right now dude yeah there are
videos on YouTube right now of Americana
it's also called you all want to look it
up Lasorda Ville Lake is what they've
rebranded as for like two years but it
closed and I think Oh 99 it's it's a
ghost town year yeah they sold awful
like the roller coasters and stuff so
it's maybe maybe because we have at
least a certain a little bit of clout we
can throw around the Netflix name from
our last documentary maybe they let us
in there to film some stuff maybe he did
it's like and it's so sad nostalgia
because I remember Leigh but that's the
danger of nostalgia like I don't get any
value from the place but of course I've
been on YouTube looking at old videos
and so I derailed you from the generic
brand of everything yeah why they were
like they were like sponsored by RC
there was no wonderly I'm not I mean
they chose Americana to sponsor right
well here's it here so here's the thing
and I think they own 7up I assume they
still do I
that was like their big thing yeah yeah
a seven-hour resting so here's the my
point bringing up the whole coke pepsi
7up thing it's like just because it's a
brand doesn't make it a good thing those
are all terrible things those are just
sugar those things are bad for you yeah
and so a brand doesn't make it
trustworthy or good it just makes it a
brand yeah I mean if here's what Leslie
I would say go listen to episode number
56 yeah that is where Josh and I do talk
about some brands it's specific to
clothing right but again those are
preferences example brand is not going
to a brand itself is it gonna make you
better or worse right it is just a brand
but what's funny is like the the way I
and maybe I interpreted the question
wrong Josh you tell me but the way I
interpret the question was is how can I
buy more responsibly what what what
brands are more responsible for the
environment okay what brands more
responsible if you want to have more if
you want to be more responsible to the
environment consume less yes there is
not a brand that is going to save the
environment right there is in fact there
are there are brands of Lake what the by
brand - right like there are brands like
the against malaria foundation is a
technically Ashe Rand
sure I guess I'm talking about when it
comes to more goods yeah consumer goods
when it comes to a brand with consumer
goods but there are there are brands
like with paper plates and bowls like
there's this new thing where it talks
about this is a net positive for
landfills when you bury this bowl with
other garbage and actually helps the
other garbage decompose faster with that
logic we should be we should be air
dropping these paper poles and all the
landfills and all over the world this is
our healthy decomposing one landfills
they're gone now right there isn't even
a landfill just wrap up all your trash
into this paper plate and they did
disappear now I think to a certain
extent I'm not trying to I'm not trying
to like this any brands that do that
because I think to a certain extent they
probably do have a point and there's
science to back up how it will help
other things decompose but ultimately if
want to be responsible to the
environment switch to one car less buy
less things go ahead and it's certainly
better than then you're putting plastic
in a landfill so so the question is can
we be more responsible with the things
that we that we purchase yes and I think
it what it comes down to are those
individual things right uh not
necessarily a brand yeah perfect
and when I think of brands that I don't
support it usually gets into a political
realm and well that's that's just
divisive so I'm not going to talk about
that here on the podcast right but my
point is is that when I consider brands
it's you usually doesn't have to do with
you know what's gonna have a better
impact on the environment because when I
think about brands like you know like a
PC versus a Mac they're both pretty
crappy for the environment yeah so what
I do is I'll buy a computer cuz we you
know I need a computer right and then I
hold on to it for the absolute longest
time I can hold on to it right and when
I can replace it or replace it so I mean
my point is is that there are things
that no matter no matter what which
brand you buy that company may not be
the most responsible company on the on
the planet don't leave it don't leave it
to the company to be responsible with
your consumer purchases leave it up to
yourself that's a pity
podcast I'll put that in there yeah well
I mean I think about brands I think
about this si from our friend Colin
right and he wrote this essay a while
ago from 2012 it has an update in 2017
and it's called loyalty or happiness it
goes a little something like this brand
loyalty demands that you keep buying
products from a specific company no
matter what you like the brand so why
wouldn't you support their efforts think
about that for a moment brand loyalty
means that even if another brand has a
superior product you'll continue to buy
the inferior one in fact it generally
means you won't even acknowledge the
other product superiority or existence
in the first place you'll spend your
money where you've spent it before
because that's
where you've spent it in the past that's
a bad reason to buy something from a
brand well I bought it before so I'm
gonna buy it again now don't get me
wrong
past performance can be indicative of
potential future performance but it's
not always indicative of future
performance dude there is craftsman is a
great example of that like like I'm not
a tool guy craftsman is a brand that's a
brand of tools yeah I'm not tool guy but
this is a brand of tools that back in
the 80s early 90s people went nuts for
yeah it was this very you know not only
was an american-made but it was this
very very reliable good quality product
and so I know cool guys who when they
had to you know in the early 2000s
they'd replace their craftsman stuff or
buy new tools what for whatever job they
needed and they just bought craftsman
because of the brand loyalty right well
craftsman they know that they had their
loyalty so what craftsman did at a
certain point is they now things are not
all built in America and the quality has
gone way way down because they don't
have to rely on the quality of the
quality of their product because they've
done such a good job
I'm indoctrinating people with their
brand they could sit on the name yes and
Apple can do that right now
and thankfully they still make
relatively good widgets but there will
be a time where it's like I've heard Joe
Rogan talking about the terrible
keyboards on Apple recently he's like
you know when I write I want to be able
to feel the keys and and like I can't
feel it so I he's moved over to a
Windows computer for his writing just
because the and to me that is like
avoiding the brand loyalty but but
embracing the brands that make the best
thing right now
so the craftsman is one example or Ford
versus Toyota or Chevy versus I was
probably better example a Chevy's were
the best car and the 70s and then in the
80s and then all of a sudden the 90s
came along and it was like what happened
this piece of junk is falling apart on
the lot and the sad part is like you
still have people in the 90s no it's
still the best because there's still
caught up in the brand and then
eventually people realize like well no
this Toyota XR driving you
I both drive Toyota's now really it
would be wrong of us to say I'm going to
drive Toyota's for the rest of my life
yeah no because if Toyota starts making
a crappy product I don't want to have
brand loyalty to it that it just means
making a bad decision that's what brand
loyalty ultimately is so I'll read a
little bit more of this and they'll put
a link to this essay in the show notes
as well this is why most companies dream
about winning the loyalty of their
customers they needn't compete quite so
hard with their rivals when they know
you'll buy regardless of how their
product measures up
loyalty we'll often consider to be a
highly desirable trait results in our
ignoring better opportunities in favour
of the ones that are more familiar
instead of taking the road that's most
favorable for us personally loyalty
instructs us to take the one that's most
favorable for the company we're
currently we currently work for instead
of being the person we want to be with
instead of being with the person we want
to be with loyalty compels us to stick
with the person we once wanted to be
with because they got there first that's
the way to think about this is just
because someone got there first so I
could talk about a few brands that I
currently get value from the pants I'm
wearing our mission workshop the shirt
I'm wearing is a mission workshop most
of their stuff is made in America or
Canada or some other place where you
know there is not going to be any kind
of child labor labor or unfair wage
practices as a result you tend to pay
more but and just because you're paying
more for something doesn't mean better
quality either in this case you're
paying more and you're getting good
quality however his mission workshop
next week next month next year a decade
from now produce worst quality I
personally would find it less appealing
yeah now just because mission workshop
works for me and the size of my body I'm
60 245 pounds
these same clothes aren't going to work
well for you necessarily right now you
own a pair of mission workshop pants or
different kind of pants they're bigger
version of pants that I would wear and
so you
find value in them as well but not
necessarily we both wear different
brands of t-shirts not because of well I
have brand loyalty to one place you know
that you like now this one works better
for me some other brands that work well
for me you and I we share a Doxie
scanner right yeah so a photo scanner
like that is a brand that has worked
well for us we did something called a
scanning party shot even put a link to
the the scanning party it's an essay
that we wrote in the show notes about
scanning the excess stuff I just did a
living room conversation about what to
do with old DVDs and old VHS tapes and
old photos and old yearbooks I did a
living room conversation in YouTube
about them one of the the answers is if
you have a Doxie scanner or there are
other services you can use to scan these
things our website is hosted by Bluehost
that is a hosting company that we use
that I feel really good about there
other just fine hosts out there and
there are other free ways to do a blog
as well you know you can get on tumblr
and start a blog today blogspot I'm sure
is still a thing you could get out there
and do it doesn't have to be barriers
out there and so it's something that
we've used but there are other
alternatives just because it's something
that you and I use doesn't mean it's the
best thing that it it's the thing that's
best for you yeah I'm trying to think if
there are any brands that I completely
avoid because of the way that they treat
the environment or or anything there's
not really again it goes the political
stuff like out for like certain well
actually like one of them is it's a
fast-food restaurant but I never eat
there anyway it'd be the last food
restaurant every day it's like I avoid
the thing I already avoided I avoid that
crack deal but are there any brands that
you avoid that that youth that are
irresponsible with whether it's the
environment or whether it's yeah any
anything that's fast
anything that is fast fashion I avoid
hmm
for two reasons one is we throw away 88
pounds of clothes a year so if I really
wanted a shirt from H&M I'm sure I could
find plenty of use shirts if for some
reason I wanted our slashed one in the
don't say that you could repair that's
the other problem is they're a plaintiff
hmm does this specifically but there are
other companies who will there's 52
seasons a year for Mex and I were
walking past one of these fast fast fast
fashion stores the other day and she
goes it's amazing every time we walk by
the store the entire inventory of the
store is different
we've never been inside it but every
time we walk past like the entire
inventory he's changed out once a week
and what do they do with the old clothes
they just cut them up and you're always
right off anyway yeah and crazy dude in
itself and so so we can't give them away
or because that's not it right off right
but if we slash them you know throw in a
dumpster right then that's a write-off
yeah and then we go it spit on homeless
people afterward right good that's what
it feels like yeah
so here's here's what I think about I
think about what you said early on
consuming less so I I consume probably
90% less from what I did in my 20s maybe
even more than 90% let's just call it
90% yeah by consuming 90% less and
focusing on companies that that I find
value in but also I know they are not
killing puppies yes they're not killing
puppies and I can I could say all right
even if I if I support a company like
Apple who may have may or may not have
questionable practices in the the
building of their phones right you look
at Foxconn and the documentaries that
have been done yeah Foxconn and when I
when I look at that it's I'm also not
going out and buying a new Apple phone
every single year I mean back in our
corporate days I mean you and I would go
through three or four phones a year
probably dude you know for that
sometimes one a month yeah because we
had access to them right and so like I
would just consume consume consume so by
radically reducing our consumption the
brands matter less I'm just saying they
don't matter but I'm saying they matter
less because we're the best way to
affect change is to consume less and
ultimately that leads
to having a better life because you're
usually when you consume less you're
creating yeah as well well dude the the
the American people specifically are
marketed to the most out of any other
people in the world and we have our
consumption habits as a nation you you
know on an average you and I probably
fall below the average of consumption
definitely fall away of all the average
but but my point is is that you know
listening to two yokels talk about
consuming less it might sound crazy
because of the habits that we have got
into as a nation but but you know with
with this American freedom we have it
comes as great responsibility for us to
consume responsibly yeah it doesn't mean
don't consume that that's not the
message we want to put out that course
it means that yes we all need to consume
some stuff and that stuff is going to
make our life better consuming better
meals you know when I had dr. Tommy wood
on the podcast we were talking about
like if you if you have a cheat meal
what he's like he's like you know what
every once awhile I'll eat a piece of
cake but it better be a good piece of
cake as opposed to when you and I were
like fat kids it was just like well
what's the hostess cake I'll grab from
the shelf and eat it was garbage man I
don't know why but that just made me
really want pizza cuz I haven't had
pizza in so long especially with
pineapple I [ __ ] love pie on one
heated like you probably we just lost
half our audience yeah because I like
pineapple on pizza but you probably
don't want Little Caesars you're not
craving Little Caesars over like if you
were to go have a piece of pizza right
now you know I'm gonna run with Little
Caesars real quick get the five four
five special or whatever the hell it is
you're completing fast food places but
yeah but it's all the same yes you put
Arby's and and those Caesars in a
blender and I handed you both in a cup
the layouts the same thing literally the
same thing blend it up yeah so um what
other brands do I like these are some
marrow the brand is strong I'm a big fan
of Jesus and marrow of
they just left complex yeah they're on
no they're on vice land they're going
the Showtime it's like my favorite TV
show but their tagline is the brand is
strong just finish out this this essay
with with Colin before we dive into the
lightning round here he says instead of
focused on loyalty
I would suggest we've approached both
our product purchases and our
relationships analytically if we take
the time to figure out what we want and
what is best for us based on those once
the company's selling to us may just
realize they're selling to the wrong
demographic or making the wrong product
and the people were with may realize
that we're not ideal for them either
this is not to say that we should all be
opportunists moving from one shiny new
thing to the next shiny new thing
regardless of the company or person in
question but it does mean that if
properly thought through a change in
direction is not an ignoble act in fact
such a shift could be the most
beneficial thing for everyone involved
and here's a little update here at the
end want to make a lot of people feel
uncomfortable question the value of
loyalty in their presence the this
nobility of loyalty is so ingrained in
most cultures that the very idea that it
might not be a good thing can spark
righteous anger or holy terror and some
I see that some people who have brand
loyalty where it's like of course this
is the best thing oh yeah and whether
that is a Toyota evangelist a Tesla
evangelist and Apple evangelist I'm not
gonna evangelize for any product or
service I can tell you what I get value
from when I talk about mission work shop
or someplace like that but I also I'm
not going to say well I stand behind
this company no matter what yeah well I
think people too like they have
preferences and they are their
preferences that they really really
enjoy yes so when someone else prefers
something different it makes a kick it
can potentially make one feel less oh
that person doesn't prefer what I prefer
but I really prefer this and here's why
I prefer you need to prefer this too as
opposed to questioning why do I prefer
that's the thing Colin said here is he
said take time to figure out what you
really want and then you find the brands
that will serve that one recently I'm on
the website we put out that the the
comparison the list of essential items
non-essential items and junk we all know
what the essentials are mm-hmm
we need to figure out what the non
essentials are those are things that we
want the things that truly add value to
our lives
the problem where we really get caught
up as we mistake all this extra junk
other people's preferences other
people's added values mm-hmm
we say oh but that's going to add value
to my life too yeah
but it may not and so what do you want
and then one of the things that are
appropriate for that life speaking of
Colin Ryan did you know that he is you
know he's doing that over the next year
have you have you seen this dude I have
but I'm totally I know I said he's
something when traveling yeah so our
friend Colin has something to do with
time-traveling yes he's figured it out
finally he's figure out how to how to
travel 24 hours in one day oh my god no
he saw our friend Colin right he is the
person who introduced us to minimalism a
decade ago now holy moly yeah man
a decade ago he introduced us to the
concept of minimalism he's more than
that he was not as nine years ago yeah
more than that no it was 2009
oh yeah yeah so so he he introduces to
the idea of minimalism and then we fell
down the rabbit hole and were introduced
to a bunch of other minimalists and when
we first discovered him yo Colin was
travelling to a new country over four
months and he didn't think the country
was based on where his readers sent him
basically they all voted on his website
and so he at the time was like an
Argentine and Iceland and India and and
I don't know a bunch of other countries
Romania yeah yeah and and so he was
going to different countries every four
months based on the votes of his readers
and then he did the last couple years he
said okay I want to try to have a home
base
a while so he let his readers vote on
the state he was going to stand so they
voted on I think they did like voting on
places that make him uncomfortable
right so when he would move to a place
he would want to live there like a local
so he wouldn't like get an air B&B or
you live in a hotel for four months he
would read the first two paragraphs on
Wikipedia and then just show up in the
country I have to find a way to rent an
apartment or whatever and so when he
came back to the states well the first
time I came back he lived with us for
seven months in Missoula Montana and we
started a symmetrical press our
publishing company and then he did more
traveling and then came back to the
States and said okay I'm gonna live in a
city for a year when I have a home base
so I can focus on on my podcast his
podcast is called let's know things and
focus on more video self on his YouTube
channel and so they voted on Kansas and
so he picked Wichita right and he and I
had a conversation about he learned a
whole lot from living as sort of very
conservative conservative state and
that's where the Koch brothers the the
city is basically named after the Koch
brothers it could be Koch brothers
Kansas instead of Wichita and after that
they voted on Tennessee and so he's
lived in Memphis for the last year and
that his his one-year lease is almost up
there so he's learned a lot he's cooked
for himself every meal for the last he's
become a good chef basically a chef but
a good cook he's cooked all his own
meals and now for the next year he's
going he is bought an RV like an 80s RV
and you remember this now he's
simplifying his life once again he's
moving from like 700 square feet to 200
square feet he's gonna live in this RV
for the next year he's gonna travel
around all of North America he's gonna
go on a year-long tour yes and so he's
going to 26 cities for two weeks at a
time and he's gonna have an event in
each city and I was thinking about
Leslie her she's from Denver so I
reached out to to Colin Leslie I'm gonna
give you two tickets that well Collins
really gonna give you two tickets to his
he's gonna do a tour stuff a lot of
these are free or really inexpensive to
go to because he's gonna do he's gonna I
think he's doing two events in each city
he's gonna do like a live podcast where
he's sort of flushes out these ideas of
his podcast which is called let's know
things he tries to learn things out loud
in front of an
so it's like let's know things to get
let's learn things together basically so
he's gonna do this event where he learns
things in front of people but he's also
gonna do a sort of book tour stop it's
called the becoming tour and so he wrote
a book recently about becoming who the
person who we want to be right and so he
is gonna spend the next twenty six weeks
going to tour I'm sorry 52 weeks gonna
26 different cities and and doing like
living in the city locally for two weeks
and his this RV to be coming tour so
many innuendos not enough time yes well
it's really about becoming the person
you want to become and and and and what
he's talking about is how that changes
over time how is ever-evolving like the
person you want to be become you you'll
become that person but then who do you
want to become after that right and he
said that's how I'm interpreting so I'm
probably gonna go I'm definitely gonna
crash his la stop that he's gonna have I
might go to his Salt Lake stop and maybe
his Jacksonville stop as well
maybe if I can convince Ryan dragged him
along will will show off together I yeah
I would love to this is because the
Jacksonville one I think is in December
so I was hoping to does it start it
starts I believe in September for
September because it's right around the
corner come on it's the next month or
within the next couple months and so is
that the only southeast in Florida its
yeah I think he's just doing
Jacksonville floor so if we're down in
st. Pete for our coffee shop then we can
plan a trip around that maybe just take
a drive over yeah that'd be great
and crash a few of his stops and who
knows we may crash a few others I can't
promise you anything but if you show up
to one of Collins either free or
inexpensive tour stops then who knows we
may we may show up as a special guest
you can find all the details to that
over at becoming tor.com we don't get
anything for telling you that we just
really really like Colin and hope you
give him a shot you could also check out
his podcast it's called let's know
things all right Ryan we'd love to hear
what you all have to say so if you have
a comment or a tip about buying things
especially buying things deliberately
then give us a call for a four zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine if
you have a comment or a tip you can also
send a voice
memo right from your phone to podcast at
the minimalists comm will air our
favorite comments and tips on a future
episode and stay tuned to the end of
this episode for this week's listener
comments and tips and oh by the way
we're also looking for questions about
sex and love and business and jobs
and sleep those are five different
topics sex love business jobs and sleep
for five different future episodes so if
you call up with a question about those
you're much more you can call with a
question about whatever but you're much
more likely to get your question aired
if you call up with a question about sex
or love or sleep or jobs or business all
right Ryan what time is it it's time for
our lightning round where we answer
questions from social media we're on
Twitter Facebook and Instagram at the
minimalists during the lightning round
this were Ryan and IH do our best to
answer every question was just a short
shareable lesson hundred forty character
response we also put the text of these
minimal Maxim's in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pit the answers
on social media if you'd like and now
you can find all of our quotes in one
place all of our pithy answers over at
minimal Maxim's calm all right our first
lightning round question is from Nick
would you rather spend more money on a
better product or spend less money on a
product you might need to replace later
on
well my pithy answer is this maybe we
can talk about a little bit Ryan more
isn't better only better is better and
so sometimes more is better I'm thinking
about one of the things we're gonna talk
about we could talk about it now so I
have several or donations to this food
co-op is better yeah yeah um yeah I mean
yes sometimes more is better for sure
yes sometimes more sex is better
sometimes more sex is too much right and
so I've been on both ends of that
spectrum comment redacted I'm thinking
so one of my added values later on is a
Drake's new album which is called
scorpion
Drizzy yeah he's got 25 songs on it and
that's been the big complaint from
everyone but for me it's like okay I
don't like all 25 songs in this um
really glad even 25 songs on here
because I think the songs that people
really like the singles or the ones I
don't like and so I can kind of make my
own version like I can make a great 15
song version of scorpion that is like
masterpiece level good in this case it
was one of those rarities where more was
better in this case now now I think what
when Nick is saying here is something
different like hey should I spend more
money on this thing if I can't afford it
well what do you mean by afford is so so
if you can't afford it spending more
more money is probably the wrong thing
but if you can't afford it then spending
more today will often save you money in
the long run right Ryan so if if if the
the pair of pants cost you $100 but
they're gonna last you for two years
that's better than buying 10 pairs of
$10 pants that are gonna last you one
month each you begin by the way you
don't even like them anyway right yeah
no I think about uh I learned that with
my my like shaver I bought a while ago
uh-huh like just a trimmer
yeah cuz I got like you know $8.00
trimmers that was good the $8.00 trimmer
yeah and replace it three months later
right
costing you more when you do that right
so I have this really short blog post
from Seth Godin that his question
reminded me of it's called the shortcut
crowd he said there is no market there
are markets and markets have segments
there are people who enjoy buying
expensive wine there are people who will
save up their money to have a big
wedding there are people who pay to have
a personal trainer and with within
segments there are careful consumers
traditional consumers consumers who seek
out the cutting edge there are bargain
hunters luxury snobs and people who
measure the way Consumer Reports does
often overlooked though is the fact that
in many markets particularly involving
personal finance small business and
relationships there are people who are
obsessed with the short cut they want
something that's too good to be true
they respond to big promises that offer
magical nearly instant results they want
as
they want a squeeze page a trip wire
offer a hard sell they respond to these
messages because they're a signal that a
shortcut is on offer my grandmother this
is the part that really stood out to me
Ryan because I bought a exercise bike
recently my Gretton I'll explain why in
a moment it actually saved me money so
we'll get to that my grandmother who
never exercised a day in her life bought
an exercise machine from a late-night TV
commercial when it's at gathering dust
she explained that she thought it would
do the exercise for her and was
disappointed that it didn't magically
make her fit for $99 so it goes on we'll
put a link to that because it's a it's a
longer essay than that I don't want to
read the whole thing but the part that
stood out to me there Ryan was like yeah
just buying the thing doesn't mean it's
gonna improve your life Bex and I have
been for about two months considering
buying an exercise bike and it's a it's
an expensive purchase but we've been
spending a decent amount of money at
soul cycle and not even going every
single day like going once a week or
sometimes max twice a week and that that
starts to add up pretty quickly and also
I don't have the convenience of being
able to do it in in my own house and by
the way soul cycle class is usually an
hour long and I didn't you pack half an
hour on each side to you know get there
shower or everything else also it's two
two and a half hour commitment to the
doing this exercise class that becomes a
barrier from you it was like okay what
if I want to do 20 or 30 minutes of
cardio this is a great way for me for me
to do that and so being on justify we're
actually going to spend less money over
the long run even though I'm gonna have
to spend or I had to spend a backside
it's been a good chunk of money right
now in order to buy and exercise bike
and you didn't just buy a $99 late night
commercial exercise bike all right I am
hoping it does the exercises for me
though that'd be great that's way paid
more money for my shoes by the way
remember those like those infomercials
like the electric shocks you put on your
abs and we're gonna work your abs while
you're watching TV yeah dude too good to
be true yes indeed my short answer is
this forsaking your budget is more
harmful than forsaking quality so yeah
of course if you can afford a quality
item get the quality item but if you
gotta go into debt to get the quality
item that is the wrong reason to get the
quality item yeah a good example is like
this pair of pants I'm wearing if they
were like a hundred bucks yeah and
someone can't feel like man it really
likes his pants
did you feel your Diners Club Card yes I
did well what's the brand you know where
can I get them and I told them and then
they shot me a text and they're like you
know I looked them up it's a little bit
outside of my budget do you know are
there any other sports brands that you
would recommend that maybe would have a
cheaper option and so forth and so on
yes like this is this is the pair pants
I really like I feel good in them
they're comfortable the great I can
afford them I don't have to put him up
put him on my Diners Club Card
and my friend who would have to put it
on a diners club car but they quickly
realize like oh yeah these are a good
pair of pants but I'm not gonna go out
of my way just to get a pair of pants
that Ryan has because Ryan has them and
I'm certainly not gonna go into debt to
get those pair of pants I think that is
the question that we need to be asking
Nick it's not about you know always
buying a better quality item you've got
to have room for it in your budget and
the other thing too is like how much is
it gonna cost you outside of like you
said outside of the money I mean do you
have you have time to take care of it
you have time to appreciate it you have
time to to change the oil and the thing
whatever it may be there are a lot of
costs to consider but just to sit there
and look at quality versus quantity
quantity yes that's an important factor
but I think there are a lot of other
things we need to consider before making
a purchase just over you know quality
versus quantity yeah we brought we
bought some plants for our apartment
recently and I made sure there were ones
I didn't have to water that frequently
right and the cactus right never have
the water yeah I mean we water
occasionally but let you grow that the
white and and that was a factor because
like that's part of the extra cost it's
like okay this plant does cost a certain
amount of money but what I had theirs I
have to have the space for it that's a
cost but I also have to water it do the
water daily weekly monthly and
that's it and now it's like picking up
this psychological space as well
thankfully Bex handles and she has a
calendar entry for and she knows when to
water these things otherwise I'm pretty
sure they would just die very quickly
somehow I'd find a way to kill a cactus
you put it in the dirt corner with her
we're good to go by it now I'm like yeah
I really put it in this corner where we
have the other plant that you have a
very similar plant to what having the
same exactly you just borrow every other
day yes and I was wanting to put the
cactus there and he's like well as their
direct sunlight I'm like not it's you
know it's a we have a for those of you
have watched the living room
conversations you know we have a pretty
light apartment but there isn't like the
direct sunlight there all day and he
goes well
cactuses live in the desert and there
are no dark deserts and yeah that's true
what's our next question our next
question is from Susan actually what you
were talking about some really good
lead-in to this question
what criteria do you meet before
committing to a purchase well see my
pithy answer is really lame but I
thought it was funny enough so it's like
the remember the Johnnie Cochran line it
doesn't fit you must acquit yes me I had
to work on this one for a while is so
lame like this is my lame this minimal
Maxim talk about good quality well it's
just like it's lame because it's cheesy
yeah it is refusing so if it doesn't fit
you must deep-six yeah so let's just
talk about this no it's good there's
some questions that I asked myself the
idea behind it I totally get it man it's
great so if I were to rephrase Susan's
question what criteria do you meet
before committing to a purchase there
what questions do you ask before making
a purchase so number one can I afford it
so can I afford its actual cost right
the watering the plants yeah okay can I
afford the actual monetary costs do I
have the money I'll bank if I have to go
into debt for it I can't afford it if I
don't have the space for it I can't
afford it if I have to buy something
extra for this thing I probably can't
afford it right so what is the actual
cost of the thing and can I afford that
actual cost number two will it add value
to my life what I mean by that does it
serve a purpose or does it bring me joy
or ideally both right you know the the
the
plants are a good example they they
bring joy serve as a decoration they
don't have an actual function but the
purpose is they look good now indoor
plants they actually help filter the air
as well so it does serve an additional
purpose there so does it add value to my
life doesn't serve a purpose does it
bring me joy number three what are the
alternatives to this thing sometimes I
think we don't ask this question enough
like well yes I can afford the thing I
got the money in my checking account
right and then yeah I think this thing
will serve a perv I buy another pair of
pants that would serve a purpose right
but then what's the alternative what can
I do with that extra hundred dollars
what's the alternative what else can I
do with this money what's your what's
your opportunity cost yeah exactly
yeah economic economic turn term is
opportunity cost so so what else can I
do with this money right and then the
fourth thing that I asked myself um if
I'm absolutely certain so the exercise
bike that we recently purchased would
fall into this so and I'm writing
something about this coming up so can I
wait thirty hours if it's more than
thirty dollars or thirty days if it's
greater than a hundred dollars I know I
wrote down twenty dollars but it's
actually 30 because it's the thirty
thirty rule hmm this new rule that I'm
working on here so can I wait 30s is
basic is a day or more like can at least
wait a day thirty hours if it's more
than thirty dollars can I wait a day now
there'll be some cases where I can't
wait a day right because I really need
this widget or whatever yeah it costs 35
blocks now if it's more than a hundred
dollars can I wait at least 30 days on
it again the exercise bike was it was a
great example because certainly more
than a hundred dollars and we waited
well over 30 days deliberating over this
decision in the venture we decided to
pull the trigger and and and and get it
but it was out and I could feel better
about that purchase because I know that
it's not a it wasn't an impulse buy
absolutely it was absolutely deliberate
dude I feel that way about my coffee
grinder like I have had a manual grinder
and for the last four years yeah and a
couple months ago I just I was reading
this thing where basically an electric
grinder is better than a hand grinder
and I just didn't realize that and I
really like having and making the best
cup of coffee I can in the morning right
get a lot of joy out of it so I finally
went out and I got
a grinder the reason why I had avoided
this purchase for so long cuz like a
good electric grinders over a hundred
bucks so I went spent like a hundred
twenty hundred thirty bucks on this
grinder dude it is I just got the
grinder wrap and I mean it does have the
difference but like you find you find
some muscular man to grind your coffee
for you yeah is that a euphemism you're
gonna love it
dude I cannot tell you the amount of
difference like I have I felt like I was
like [ __ ] man like I have been like
depriving myself of this not just a
convenience but it does it does produce
a better grind which produces a better
cup of coffee do you know the brand
maybe we can talk about that value I
don't but I can certainly we'll talk
about next week talk about next week
sure sounds good man I will yes we'll
put a pin in that all right here's my
short answer for you Susan a few things
to consider before making a purchase
budget occupied space and hidden costs
I think the LAT the the last one there
hidden costs that's something that I
used to forsake a lot like I'd buy a
really nice pair of like Allen Edmonds
shoes and then you're still made in
America somehow yes and they're great
it's a great shoe company don't get me
wrong
yeah um but you know polishing them up
as often as I had to polish them up
didn't really consider that when I
bought that pair of shoes right there
are just certain hidden costs that that
if we if we buy an impulse we will miss
those hidden costs and we'll regret it
later so a few things for you to
consider there Susan remember remember
Susan if it doesn't fit you must deep
six
alright PS see what I did there I'm PS
we have one more question oh man a
breathin PS we have one more question
Laura says Laura asks how do I fight the
paradox of choice at the grocery store
now she's specifically talking about
Whole Foods here and you and I often
talk about Whole Foods but I think this
applies to any large stores any any
store in general and Ryan or not you and
I are gonna have a conversation about
that and if you all want to hear our
answer to that question then you can
listen to this week's PostScript episode
PS over at the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively to our
patreon supporters that's why it is a
private podcast so if you want to
support this show and help keep this
podcast a hundred percent average
when free then head on over to the
minimalists comm slash support in
addition to our weekly PostScript
episodes the minimalist private podcast
feed includes our monthly ask the
minimalists anything episodes we've had
11 of those so far Ryan actually 12 you
count though the part 1 & 2 that we did
of number 10 remember that oh yeah we
had the mess up but we were we had the
audio for both of them so I guess
technically we have 12 ask them in
almost anything episodes which you can
find all of those over at the private
clock a speed also unreleased recordings
of our live events we just put up the
first Melbourne event that we did
earlier this year the Sydney events up
there the Tampa event the Detroit event
dudes that first Melbourne event that's
my favorite event ever dude it is like
by far my favorite event especially the
part we were talking about hand jobs
yeah we weren't talking about hand jobs
that's actually well that's true that's
true
anyway I lost my place in the script
here oh yeah oh yeah the entire back
catalogue of past private episodes you
could become a supporter you get all the
the back cattle we've done over 60
episodes now Ryan of the minimalists
private podcast and once you become a
supporter you'll receive a personal link
to our private podcast feed so that a
plays in your normal podcast player so
whatever podcast player using to listen
to this right now and as a patreon
supporter you also receive access to our
monthly live stream videos we just did
number 11 on that as well as first
access to tickets to all of our live
events before those tickets are
available to the general public find all
the details and all the good stuff over
at the minimalists comm slash support
and here is a snippet from this week's
PostScript episode
[Music]
the paradox of choice for people who are
uninformed about what the parish would
basically like it's the reason that
we're all actually turned off by the
paradox which our choice means we have
so many options that we end up not
making a decision at all right grocers
and other places actually don't want you
to have the paradox of choice then
that's why they create these I member
when we work for the telecom company
that we worked for for over a decade we
had good better best plans that's what
you want to bring it to people you want
to present people here are your three
options people like options people hate
too many options right it's like when
you go somewhere and you feel
overwhelmed you feel wrong because there
are too many options and so places try
to help you make the choice for you so
how do I deal with the be good better
best thing I create my own good better
best if there's a paradox of choice
right and so if there are so many
options I'll say okay I'm gonna pick
three and then what are the three that I
would ideally choose like what what I'm
gonna be happy with any of these three
choices okay and then which one is the
most ideal right now now most ideal
might meet most ideal because a price
most ideal because of taste most idea
because my current need most ideal
because of the time of day the chocolate
bar that I want right now here are the
three options well I'm one with no sugar
I'm gonna buy the hundred percent right
and so there's my good better best as
opposed to the four hundred chocolate
bars they have what are the three I know
are good options here's my good better
best pick one of those three I know I'm
gonna be happy no matter what
[Music]
all right and we're back Ryan it's time
for our added-value portion of the show
this is where we each talk about
something that has added value to our
lives recently so I already alluded to
this but the new Drake album it's called
scorpion now two things it came out on
my birthday happy birthday from Drake
exactly and in one of my favorite songs
on their song called elevate it's a song
about sort of I can't believe this
happened to me I couldn't imagine all
these good things happen to me and one
of the lines in there when I was making
the road trip from Cincinnati up to
Dayton and I just I had this flight
because every day is you know how does
he have experience with that I he must
have been doing tours like you know like
doing a show in Cincinnati and he talks
about refueling and having to drive from
Cincinnati after Dayton and every day I
was when I was doing the director job I
would drive live downtown Dayton because
I didn't want to live in Cincinnati
nothing against Cincinnati I just loved
Dayton and so I was making that drive
that 54 mile drive from downtown
Cincinnati to downtown Dayton every
single day and he has this line it comes
out on my birthday 25 songs he did a
side and a b-side a side is like rapping
Drake and the b-side is singing R&B
Drake and like I've listened it's 25
songs I was listened to several times he
talks about you know he had a kid and he
had that whole sort of beef with Pusha T
and his family addresses that yeah he
had to sort of if he had this great line
right he said because pushed II called
him a lie you're you're hiding a child
yeah and he said I wasn't hiding my son
from the world I was hot in the world
from my son yeah and laying like and he
has other lines about our addiction to
social media on there and there are just
some great one-liners some great lyrics
and like I said dude people a lot of
people it's funny because the love
people use things the opposite never
works all right I mean there are a ton
of different variations of that quote
yeah well the first the first person who
said it was was
venerable Bishop Fulton yeah 1925 I
didn't know that when I was first
inspired by that quote but what people
don't know is that Drake is the one that
actually inspired that quote for us yeah
and he was inspired from the last person
who was inspired from the last person
who was inspired from the dude that you
just mentioned yeah yes but it's funny
though like Drake he does he does have
this like awesome way of like sit like
rapping about some philosophical stuff
he has he's like little Turner phrases
right you know I wasn't hiding my child
from the world hiding the world from my
child and and you know what he means by
that Riley of course I want to I want to
protect my son from the nonsense now the
weird thing about this album is people
are criticizing because they're saying
it's so bloated the thing I really liked
about the album though is in the editors
note when the album description
basically if you pull it up on Spotify
or Apple music or something it has all
the criticisms of Drake like he
basically says yeah Drake doesn't rap
enough Drake sings too much Drake thinks
he's Jamaican Drake took an L like like
all of these like these criticisms that
he just addresses immediately like in in
before you even listen to the album it's
in the the sort of liner notes of the
album and people are complaining that
it's so a bloated thing but for me
what's nice it because it's all digital
now you just remove the songs that you
don't want to hear like I'm not a big
fan of the singles I'm usually not a fan
of Drake's angles but I get that a lot
of people are those are his most popular
songs for a reason yeah so to me there
are all those people bitching him
complaining to like they're still
listening to the album that's what
cracks me up yeah and they're saying oh
well he gives too many thought then get
rid of the ten songs you dislike you
have the ability to delete songs in your
library yes and you can move it listen
and you can love the 15 song you that
you wrote actually you're right the
songs that you really really love and
make it your own album yeah and and then
that's like when people get played about
our podcast being too long sometimes
turn the thing off right make it a
two-parter yeah it's two minutes if you
press pause right two minutes in yes yes
indeed so the new Drake albums called
scorpion
see oh this journal in this new journal
amuse we talked about journals a couple
weeks ago and one of our podcasts which
episode was that anyway he sent this to
me and that so he when he says he's
talking about drew kapner yeah am I
saying his name right taping her yeah
taping her yeah oh that guy yeah who did
her soundtrack from minimalism yeah he's
uh did you see that dance video that
girl did no dude she did this whole I
don't know if it's interpretive dance
but it's like a modern style dance to
one of the songs off our documentary
look at that she tweeted you yesterday
the day before I open I get a chance
it's really really good I'll check it
out so actually we'll put that we'll put
that in our show notes what the length
of her dance it's pretty good so drew an
8 formed the band Nate Nate Nate Piper
he's from Utah and drew is the lead
singer of possibly my favorite band of
all time band called parlor Hawk now
they have only two albums will probably
only ever have two albums their second
album to me is a perfect album it's its
self-titled parlor Hawk but we begged
him for a while to make a a soundtrack
him and Nate partner up they made a band
called we vve and they had Italy capital
v e yeah and so they did the minimalism
soundtrack which you can find wherever
you listen to music they put it out on
all the streaming platforms but we got
him to do it and we basically just paid
for studio time we were really grateful
for that they decided to do that but
he's a product designer he makes things
intentionally he runs a company called
everyman and they just started this
Kickstarter so if you're looking for a
new journal the thing that I like about
this cuz I usually use those just mol
skins now here's here's what I this is a
practice of me letting go and and
podcast Sean and I had an argument over
the so that wasn't a real argument but I
I just throw out like my journal as soon
as I'm done with it
like I don't want to keep like it's
because it's hard for me to let go of it
that's all those things I wrote in their
note for me I get rid of it
now this this is a beautiful journal I'm
not saying you need a new journal you
probably don't need a new journal so
don't get it if you don't smell that man
it's I mean it smells like you want to
write smells like
leather yes it does and so it's the nice
thing about it is see these little
screws here on the side yeah this part
comes out so if you want to like it's a
nice inside sort of notebook you can and
they look great on a shelf if you want
to have people I couldn't ever get rid
of home on journals then freakin keep
your journals I don't care what you do
with your old journals right have a
shelf at your these actually look good
on a shelf you can see their Kickstarter
video so he sent this to me and I just
started using it for the notes on this
episode so I don't carry around a large
notebook all the time I like the size
this better than my big moleskin it's
the appropriate size for me if it's in
my bag early it's nice to have it my
desk just having something to write on
at my desk is is really nice and so this
is replacing my moleskin and I like the
pages are also perforated so you can you
can tear them out to turn pages out of
mole skins whoa so ruin the moleskin
yeah some of them they do have
perforated I think I think some of new
perforated just but yeah for all
intensive purposes the ones that don't
yes it'll ruin the whole Maus skin
although I'm an idiot and I started
writing on the wrong side so the actual
beginning is up here and I screwed it up
so you know I'm writing on both sides
but I've really enjoyed it so far that
said I once I'll pull this out and this
will get better with age right so this
this this cover as I continue putting
new notebooks in it will weather really
well they had a couple different colors
you know I went with the black because
my soul is black no I I just you know
aesthetically but they had some other
ones that were like tan leather and it
just looked really good they're doing a
Kickstarter for it we'll put a link to
that Kickstarter in the show us again
you probably we talked about buying
things with intention if you need a new
journal and you want something that's
gonna last a lifetime and you do
journaling and you want a good like desk
notebook I think it's a good way to to
support a brand or really a couple guys
who are behind a brand who do everything
that they do with intention so it is
called the endeavour notebook by the way
and yeah we'll put a link to that in the
show notes one last two last things I
guess our friend Carl from minimalism
that life our little side project you
know he put out an extra side project
how did he make well cuz he's a designer
but yeah he made a website wait prettier
than ours that's what he died so it's
called minimal list minimal list now it
is spelled M in m ll dot ist so it's
like minimal without the vowels only the
consonants with an L at the end dot ist
minimal list anyway I will put a link to
in the show notes as well he described
it perfectly right so I went on there I
was looking at these different things
that are on there it's an ever evolving
directory of all things minimal based on
categories and sub-categories think of
it as the ultimate bookmark for
minimalist dude I was checking out the
website and I loved how it is really
simple
yeah and you can just kind of pick a
topic but then like you can dive so deep
yes and he does such a good job of Lake
not making me feel overwhelmed right
because you get to shoot you get to
choose what you're overwhelming yourself
away right as opposed to just like
hitting you over the head with like
there's clearly no pop-ups or there's
there's no I'm right there's nothing
like it's it's aggressively simple but
has categories like if I ever were to
buy a bike I mean if I ever learned how
to ride a bike and then I bought one
like I would clearly go on and he was
like the three bikes that he finds to be
most beautiful and then books you know
he has books about minimalism like good
buy things or everything that remains or
the more of less by Joshua Becker but
then you can dive deeper into like the
subcategory but you've got the top three
in all these different categories of
tables like dining room tables and
different things that it's a really well
curated list if you're thinking about
buying something and you want to do so
with intention he has curated this this
list and that's why it's called the
minimal list in my M in M ll ist and I
want to talk to you about this Ryan you
and I had movie night we're starting to
watch the Matrix trilogy dude I cannot
believe how well the matrix held up I
know what you're to the coat it was like
90 98 or 99 I believe I think was 99
well here it's gonna be right here 1999
1999 yeah dude for that film almost
being 20 years
old yes like it just it holds up
incredibly well yeah you and I were
talking about like I think a lot of has
to do with the the green screen I think
a lot of it was done with the green
screens as opposed to like CGI which I
think CGI for 20 years ago what it made
it look pretty bad but man and this I
think the reason holds up so well is not
because of the the wonderful sort of
aesthetics of the yeah of the
cinematography right which is good yeah
the the writing in it is really good and
of course the acting is good I mean
Laurence Fishburne's top five actors of
all time probably yeah and I so I have
some of the quotes here now the reason I
printed out some of these quotes Ryan is
I think a lot of the quotes from this
movie that when the memorable ones are
so overused and they're so like a red
pill blue pill and they've did they've
taken on totally different meanings now
right but there are other sort of quotes
from here that we don't remember that
are perfect metaphors for our consumer
culture back then and today yeah this is
not so appreciably different and so
there are a few of them in here talk
about them yeah so Agent Smith when he
said I like to share a revelation that
I've had during my time here it came to
me when I tried to classify your species
humans and I realized that you're not
actually mammals every mammal on this
planet instinctly develops a natural
equilibrium with the surrounding
environment but you humans do not you
move to an area and you multiply and
multiply until every natural resource is
consumed and only and the only way you
can survive is to spread to another area
is there another organism on this planet
that follows the same pattern do you
know what it is a virus human beings are
a disease a cancer on this planet you're
a plague and we are the cure god I just
want to see the second matrix now we're
going to hopefully next week but but the
I I don't agree with that in terms of
humans but but it's human behavior quite
often right it's this if we allow our
impulses to run us right I mean at its
at its terminus like yes that is
absolutely it's it's consumer
is the virus right so I look at it as
like it there aren't there aren't other
mammals or animals that that are
consumers the way that we are except you
mean the analogy that Chris D'Elia
always talks about as barracudas right
call people kudos because like
barracudas they jump and bite it shiny
things they see the shiny object and we
often do the same thing with consumerism
we're just yeah biting at the the next
shiny thing I'll find a couple other
quotes here these are from my idea IMDB
what are you what are you trying to tell
me I can dodge bullets no Neil I'm
trying to tell you that when you're
ready you won't have to okay yes I got
chills just listening to that line Tony
do you like I cannot believe how much I
enjoyed that movie watching it for the
20th time yes I just haven't seen in
probably five years well it reminds me
of like when when these when people ask
like like do you you know is it easier
for you to to like not buy stuff now and
the honest answer is yeah but it's
because I'm not always thinking about
buying the stuff anymore it's like when
I become a minimalist well I buy fewer
things and then the answer would be like
when you become a minimalist you won't
have to yeah because you're focused on
what is actually more important in your
life that's really what middle is about
the intentional so curation yeah good
spin on it so that's what as soon as I
heard that that's what I thought about
what Oh obviously one of my favorite
lines is when like they just got him out
of the little you know embryo looking
thing yes and he's like what am i eyes
hurt yeah and he's like because you've
never used them yeah I was like damn
like that is such a good metaphor for
like what for minimalism when we take
this on it hurts man there's a lot of
pain there's a lot of difficulty letting
things go there's a lot of difficulty
with changing habits and it's because
we've never looked at life that way
before like yes there is this painful a
kind of beginning that comes with
minimalism right but yeah once we get
used to it yeah you won't even have to
buy thanks right yeah
I think that's actually that's not true
you will have to buy some stuff yeah
yeah but but you won't be worried about
right and I think that's the thing
because you developed the habits and the
rules that are appropriate for you then
you stop worrying about like I don't
worry about buying things anymore right
it's because I know that I'm deliberate
with the things I bring into my life I'm
also deliberate with the things that I
choose to hold on to and the the the
eyes thing is a much better metaphor
than the red to blue the red pill blue
pill thing has just become so overused
like yes okay minimalism is the red pill
it opens up the the the truth or
whatever fine whatever you you can say
that if you want but the better metaphor
is I open your eyes mm-hmm and and right
now we're walking around with our eyes
closed so to speak because yeah well I
think I'm sorry you finished a metaphor
Oh God what I was thinking is like our
eyes closed is living off the impulse
exactly that's that's what living off of
impulses and that brings me that brings
me to the next quote is from number of
mouths wait he designed the the woman in
the red dress oh yeah
and I disagree with this quote because I
think it's the opposite of true Mao said
to deny our own impulses is to deny the
very thing that makes us human I would
say the very thing that makes us human
is our ability to deny our acting on
every impulse the ability to not act on
every impulse is what makes us a better
human being
tweet that podcast Sean all right if you
could drop this mic over here yeah so
there are a couple others maybe we'll
just find one more that makes a little
bit of sense
dude it's I cannot I just can't believe
how well that movie held up yeah yeah
yeah so yes yes yes yes yes yes
Morpheus oh of course all the best lines
are from Morpheus have you ever had a
dream neo that you were so sure was real
what if you were unable to wake from
that dream what would you how would you
know the difference between the dream
world and the real world and and I think
sometimes like we get so caught up in
the dream world
dude sentimentality mentalities the
first thing I think of the dream world
is a dream world of sentiment yeah and I
think of nostalgia yes very similar
things right yeah right and I think
those two things are often related right
like we hold on to these sentimental
items only because of the nostalgia and
that's the danger of nostalgia it's it's
this dream world because that world
didn't actually exist well I remember
like we were filming this new
documentary the minimalists lesses now
we were back at my old childhood home
down there in Warren County Ohio you
bought in you bought the place
no and here's a house sentiment it was
III didn't have the $40 on me I I
wouldn't buy that you couldn't give me
that house it's boarded up man only um
anyway leg did knock down anyway but
like I do remember like just being in
y'all neighborhood and having like this
good feeling but there was nothing I
mean generally nothing good about it
there was 10% good 90% bad but then like
for whatever reason like these the
nostalgia oh yeah the comfort of
whatever but it's that's just pulling
forward the the good stuff that's a
dream world because the real world of
back then was chaos it was electricity
being cut off it was oh we don't have we
didn't pay the water bill this month so
we got it got turned off it was it was a
different world and so like yeah being
able to wake up from the dream world is
what minimalism has allowed me to do
alright I think that's it for my added
value Ryan what's adding value to your
life recently well it's funny man cuz
the so we we know someone who works for
Lululemon and member they wanted to give
us some clothes to try out yeah Aaron
yeah and and and I'm assuming it's
because you know they want us to they
want to have our buy-in because if you
can get the minimalist to buy into your
product right then it must be a really
really good product right and our good
friend dr. Ryan green he has went way
out of his way to like just you know
tell me how much he really enjoys these
products so I know you went and they
tried to give you some stuff for free oh
they did give it to you for free I did
yeah but then you uh you went and
donated some money in there
name yes I know exactly how much it was
so Aaron gave me and I actually wear the
the Lululemon jacket they gave me yeah
and I have a long-sleeve t-shirt it's
very similar to this that they gave me
that I that I really liked yeah the
jacket I especially like I probably wear
that thing almost every every day and I
was wearing it this morning like when I
was doing my stretches and and so they
gave me these things and I just tallied
up what she would let me pay for them
and so I just like went on their website
when I got home when I tallied up the
amount and I added it up and I just
donated that to give well.org
I took a screenshot of the donation i
sent at the air and i said here you go
it's donated in your name so it's funny
because i didn't really even think about
taking those things for free like i
wouldn't have thought anything of it and
then you kind of explain to me your
thought process behind it which actually
why don't you explain your thought
process behind not taking something for
free well because then i feel compelled
to talk about it positively and also if
i do talk about it positively then i
feel like i've been bought in some way
yeah you don't want to owe anyone
anything exactly so so keeping that in
mind because i didn't want to try out
the products mm-hmm I just I didn't tell
and I was going I just went and bought
actually this pair of pants most
comfortable freaking I love their
t-shirts mm-hmm and this is a thing it
may not be an awesome t-shirt for you
right it may not be an awesome teacher
for anyone listening this but I'll say
like I'd really find their t-shirts
really comfortable in this pair of like
athletic sweats that I bought they do a
really good job of of with men's apparel
I just had no idea always thought a
Lululemon as like this yogi you know I
had to let go to yoga class and you know
drink caramel macchiatos yeah in order
to wear Lululemon yeah and be a woman -
I didn't really say they've made a pair
for men right but uh but yeah it's like
it's it's it's it's actually I really do
enjoy their brand and the one thing I
really appreciate about them and I'm not
just you're not gonna pay for this by
the way like I really appreciate this
brand because of that the saying that
they have I forget exactly how it goes
but it's something about people who
sweat together build stronger
relationships right yeah yeah it's and
it's absolutely true like it's
when I think about like dr. Ryan green
and I we hang out the most with with
exercising in some way going to the gym
going to SoulCycle we just did this like
Nike training class like the
relationship I have with him it feels
much different than a relationship I
have with someone when I just hang out
with them every once you know once in a
while I go to the comedy comedy club or
or go to the the movies or whatever
there's a much different type of
relationship being built there and I I
never even thought about that until I
heard dr. Ryan telling me about their
philosophy so I definitely will
recommend them the other thing I
recommend too is retired inspired by
Chris Hogan I think you already
recommended it on one podcast but maybe
a long time ago yeah I'm gonna recommend
a book here's the thing dude you know
it's so a lot of a lot of people a lot
of my mentoring students they they got
money problems a lot of people have
money problems if you have money
problems and you don't have a budget
stop talking about your money problems
like it fresh because every single book
I read it starts with a budget and it's
so true if you've got money problems
come up with a budget do not [ __ ] about
any of your money problems until you've
come up with a budget then let's talk
about your budget you're sticking to
right exactly it goes back to that the
thought experiment like well yeah I have
a budget but I don't stick to it well
then you don't I mean maybe you have a
theoretical budget yeah yeah exactly and
I'm not trying to undermine people's
money problems I'm not trying to to say
that you know managing money is easy I'm
not trying to you know undermine the the
actual problems people do have Ryan
you're not having money problems for the
first 31 years of our lives yes it's
absolutely rapport and when we were
wealthy yes all I'm trying to say though
is if you're someone out there listening
to this you know like oh I got all these
money problems and the minimalists they
don't understand and and and why would
they even say that come up with a budget
first yeah and then talk to me about
about your money problems
the budget is is so key in two and two
having no money problems or making those
go away however you want to look at it
yeah well speaking of Chris Hogan I
think it's a great book he has a good
podcast as well it's also called called
retire inspired yeah and
he talks about retirement but he does so
in a way that he frames it for people
our age I mean the problem with
retirement as we started thinking about
it when we're like in our late 50s or
something yeah and that's better to
think about it when you're 55 then when
you're 75 and all of a sudden you're
like well I should probably think about
this whole retirement thing it's the
best time to plant a tree was 20 years
ago the second best time to plant a tree
is now and so now is the best time to
think about retirement if you're 16
years old and you're listening to this
we have a lot of teenagers listen now
now is the time for you to start think
about retirement
Beks and I just revamped the way she's
doing retirement and she's maxing out
her Roth IRA and she's trying to max out
a SEP IRA which is like a in you and I
have SEP IRA as well it's like an
individual 401k for a self-employed
people basically right and so you can
see well you see my retirement accounts
that you're interested in that over at
the minimalists comm slash retirement
you can see how my retirement is set up
and we set up something similar for
backs she has a Roth IRA though I have a
traditional you can read why on that
post there but and then also if you want
to budget every dollar was a great app
that we've talked about before with Dave
Ramsey's team has put that together and
then also our budget the budget you and
I put together is the minimalists comm
slash freedom and people can find that
we'll put links to those in the show
notes yeah but yeah it's I agree it's a
great book I want to go back to the
Lululemon thing for a second because
there's one thing I forgot to mention go
for the clothes that they make like this
t-shirt it's called the five-year
t-shirt like it's I think it's 50 bucks
but like it is meant to last for at
least five years which I really
appreciate the they factor in the wear
and tear on your clothes yeah and and
and that's important because it goes
back to the question I think was Nick
that asked earlier about quality versus
quantity right all right and and I mean
sometimes I and by the way it doesn't
mean that again like you said doesn't
mean that that shirt will necessarily
work for someone else but you know if
you are buying that that you're you're
getting some sort of quality if if you
can afford it if you can afford it I
tend to spend more upfront if it's worth
spending more upfront yeah because
otherwise you're gonna pay for it on the
back end yeah yeah pay for it and
letting go which that's a cost in and of
itself
all right let's move on the right here
right now is where we talk about what's
going on the lives of the minimalist
will be with Chris Hogan really soon and
some other folks from Dave Ramsey's team
we're going out on the simply southern
tour we're talking about money and
minimalism we're gonna be in Alabama and
we're gonna be in Kentucky and we're
gonna be in Tennessee we're gonna be
with Rachael Cruz Chris Hogan and
Anthony O'Neill one person in each of
those three cities were gonna talk about
money and minimalism a hundred percent
of the profits go to the gym city market
the nonprofit food co-op that we're
trying to help build in our hometown of
Dayton Ohio which has one of the largest
food deserts in the entire country they
know how is also the second hungriest
city for families in the United States
so if you want to help out with that you
can attend if you're anywhere in the
south I've already had well actually
I've heard we have a couple people from
Canada coming down to the Louisville
stop which is good news
it looks like the National stop is going
to sell out relatively soon
we definitely need your help in
Louisville and Birmingham as well so so
if you are thinking about coming go
ahead and come on out a hundred percent
of the profits that Ryan and I make are
gonna go to the gym city market if you
want to contribute to the gym city
market outside of that if you want to
help us build this food co-op you want
to donate some money for my 37th
birthday head on over to the minimalists
com size Dayton you can read more about
the the coop when it's gonna be built
how they're gonna help serve families in
West Dayton which by the way doesn't
have a single grocery store in the
entire west side of Dayton right now the
last 30 days or last month for 30 days
rather Ryan's all of June we recorded
living room conversations living room
conversation that's our theme song well
that was the theme song whenever Ryan
join me so Ryan join me for at least a
handful of these all so that's how you
know I was there yeah that's right and I
I brought some other special guests on
Beck's was on for one of them actually
he was on for three of them if you see
here on the background of two of them
she was like doing a work out there it a
couple of them that I that I recorded
but she did she actually answered a
question about minimalism for families
with me as well I brought Ella on for
one
of them how many toys should kids on her
and I talked about how many toys she
should own and well we brought TK
Coleman Ellen talked about quitting a
job that you hate yeah so here are some
of the questions that we answered over
at the living room conversation this is
oh by the way all on our YouTube channel
youtube.com slash the minimalists what
steps do you need to take for the
minimalist life to happen how much stuff
should you get rid of how can I get the
whole family on board with minimalism
what if you can't turn your passion into
a career how do you get rid of things
you might need in the future how many
toys should your kids have how do
minimalist handle one-time purchases
what the minimalists do for fun when is
it okay to throw away find partners
things what do you think about
downsizing your home when you have kids
how do you deal with criticism how do
you quit the job you hate should you
break up with your girlfriend if she is
not a minimalist how do you introduce
minimalism to a friend how do you get
people to stop buying you gifts why it
does minimalism
why doesn't minimalism why doesn't
minimalism have color style or
personality
what's one item you'd grab if your house
was on fire
when have you taken minimalism too far
what should you do with your old photos
school books DVDs and VHS tapes what is
your budget for clothing how do you let
go of sentimental items what books do
you recommend to get out of debt what's
the difference between advertising and
marketing what's one thing you've let go
recently what's one thing you regret
minimizing as a minimalist what items do
you keep in your car we did a field trip
to my car when I was at LAX picking you
guys up from the airport I got this
question and I'm like alright well I've
got my car here let's just take a field
trip and I show you the four things that
I keep in my car what are you carry in
your pockets every day I did a video
here I just emptied all all my pockets
and and show people what I kept in my
pockets and you'd actually be surprised
I probably keep more things in my
pockets than a lot of people do you ever
want to quit social media how do you
avoid procrastination and how do the
minimalist spend their money I'd say I
really enjoyed the experiment I'm
certainly not gonna do videos every
single day because I became stressful
after a while jack trying to do a video
every day but I can see doing a regular
thing
conversation once a week and answer your
question so you can join us over at the
YouTube channel and we'll do more of
these living room conversations maybe we
will get a Ryan over to my house more
often to do to do these and we'll post
them occasionally over on the YouTube
channel let's see what else we have
going on I mention my birthday oh
speaking of YouTube channel if you check
out the videos version of this podcast
if you want to see the video version of
this podcast we put it up a day early
now so this podcast usually comes out on
Tuesdays the video version because of a
whole complicated series of events that
has to happen to get this thing out on
time
the video version is up a day early so
it comes out on Mondays if you want to
see this podcast a day early and see
Ryan's beautiful face and his flowing
hair and all his hair PO keep going all
his glory also if you want to get the
show notes to every episode of the
podcast you can just enter your email
address over at the minimalists com that
will get you access to all the show
notes in your inbox will never sell or
give away your email address or send you
any spam but you'll also get any new
writings any new essays any new articles
that we write over at the minimalists
comm to Center your email address over
at the top ryan what else we got you
know i got those voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners here check them
out this is becky from england
I just wanted to send a message for
anyone who is considering minimizing
their social media usage so this is
something I have battled with most of my
adult life actually worked in social
media managed social media accounts for
lots of brands as well as checking my
own personal accounts in the morning and
in the evening and after being motivated
by hearing how you guys we're using your
own accounts more mindful ooh this year
and listening to a podcasts I decided to
give myself 30 days off work and off
using social media so I had a social
media detox and the important part here
and this is my tip for anyone that's
wanting to do something similar is to
document how you're feeling in a journal
so maybe a few weeks before you delete
your social media accounts
and have a bit of a reflection on how
you feel and yourself you're happy at
where you are in your life at the moment
how's your physical health how's your
mental health sleeping well what about
your relationships what do you spend
your time doing every day you happy
spending your time doing those things
every day and I was able to carry on
this journal into my digital social
media detox so I was able to see what
the changes were from that transition of
having a life way you check social media
and having a life where you don't check
social media I think the changes are so
subtle that we sometimes don't realize
you know if little things for me like my
memory improved because I was able to
actually pay attention to things that
were happening in the real world more so
than when I was subconsciously always
thinking about my social media accounts
and I think these accounts have a hold
on us in a way that we kind of don't
even realize so keeping a journal can be
a really beneficial way to do this I did
keep my paper journal and then recycled
it or you can keep an electronic journal
type on your laptop whatever but it's
these philosophies that when you look
back after the 30 days can really help
you make a decision as to whether your
social media usage is giving you more
positives or negatives and you know that
can be the catalyst for making you
decide that you want to delete your
social media accounts permanently which
is the decision I made after the 30 days
I just had far too many positives happen
in those 30 days and things that
improved in my life that it kind of
wasn't worth it so it's it's looking
back oh that journal and seeing if it's
worth sacrificing all those things for
so good luck if you do decide to have a
social media detox and if you do decide
that the cons are bigger than the pros
afterwards and you decide to come off
social media forever then well done and
enjoy life in the real world without
incessant and relentless checking of
your phone it is a wonderful place to be
my minimalist just wanted to share a
great minimalist way to enjoy books I
know in my city of Toronto you're able
to get a library card and then you're
able to sign in online
and get ebooks and audiobooks for free
straight to your phone you don't go to
the library at all that's a great way to
enjoy books you can have them on your
phone and read them anywhere or listen
to an audiobook on your commute and it's
a great way to enjoy books and not have
to stop them
hey Ryan and Josh this is Lauren and
Colorado I am responding to Sabrina who
called in on the intentionality or
intentions episode and was asking how
she can continue to remind herself as
her intentions day to day once she has
set them and I've read an article once I
think I found it on LinkedIn that
recommended that you can set your
password to email or to your computer or
to your phone to somehow encompass your
goals so when I decided to go vegan the
word vegan was a part of my password you
know when I had certain goals to reduce
my environmental footprint I use certain
words to remind myself every day that I
typed in my password that I was going to
minimize waste or reduce waste and so it
was actually a really great tip and I've
used it for the past few years and found
it to be really successful
alright y'all that's it for this episode
if you have a question for the
minimalists give us a call for 0 6 2 1 9
7 8 3 9 remember we're all we're
especially looking for questions about
sex and sleep and jobs and business and
I think there was one other Ryan love
the topic of love and so if you have any
questions that are loosely related when
you call up just say hey my question is
about love or whatever and we'll make
sure that your question makes it to the
top of the list or you can call us with
a question about anything else as well
and or you could just know instead of
calling in you send a voicemail right
from your phone the podcast at the
minimalists dot-com and if you leave
here with just one message we hope it's
this love people and use things because
the opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
bye and minimus
[Laughter]